one of the nice things about memory as a
subject of study for cognitive
psychologists is that it doesn't require
a lot of high technology to do with
experiments so we can actually do a
simple memory experiment right now that
you can test yourself with I'll just
read out a series of words and I want
you to listen to the words and um try to
remember them and then after a little
while I'll ask you some questions about
the words so we'll get started I'll read
them about one every second or so bed
rest
awake tired dream wake snooze blanket
doze slumber snore nap peace yawn drowsy
so that was a simple list of words and
what I'm gonna do now is just ask you
about some of the words that may or may
not have been on the list you can just
think to yourself now was that word part
of the list or not let's start with
snooze think about whether that was part
of the list now we'll try Apple was that
part of the list next
house was that part of the list how
about dream was that part of the list
and what about sleep was that on the
list so we just did about the lowest
technology possible memory experiment a
list of words that you have to remember
and answer questions about this
experiment was actually originally done
by researchers named James Dees and also
Roddy rota ger and Kathleen McDermott
and what they found was that people are
of course pretty good at realizing that
which words are inside the lesson which
words were not in the list but there's
one kind of mistake that they make
pretty systematically and that's falsely
saying that the word sleep was part of
the list so the word sleep wasn't in the
list that I just gave you the list was
bed rest awake tired dream wake snooze
blanket doze slumber snore nap peace
yawn and drowsy all those words have to
do with sleep but sleep was actually not
in the list yet a lot of subjects in
these in this experiment falsely think
that sleep was there and they're usually
pretty confident that sleep was in that
list also it's not sort of a marginal
it's not a marginal thing so even in a
simple situation like this just trying
to remember a few words our memories can
play tricks on us